- Before we say goodbye
we like to play a quick round of
- Drewth or Dare.
(audience applauds)
All right, we have Sean Bunch.
Hi Sean.
- Hi.
Hi Drew. Hi Ross.
How y'all doing?
- [Drew] I love your name.
- Oh, thank you.
- Sean Bunch.
- My mother gave it to me.
(Ross laughs)
So I and my boyfriend are a big
fan of yours on "Drag Race".
- Oh, thank, you're talking to me.
Thank you.
- I am, so...
(audience applauds)
- I am too.
You know, it's my daughter
Olive's favorite show.
- It is.
- Oh, she loves it.
Oh, we all love it at our house.
- I love it too, I can't
believe I get to do it.
- Well, I have a Drewth for both of you.
- [Ross] Okay.
- So, my Drewth today is
what would both of your drag names be?
- Oh.
- Do we get judged on our drag names,
the way we get judged on our pet names?
(Ross laughs)
- Not today.
- Okay.
- Oh, you know, people ask me that,
I never have a good answer for that.
I've never, I've actually
never done drag before.
Yet.
Could I just go with Nellie?
- I mean, you could go with
Nellie, but I mean, uh...
- [Ross] Do you have one for me?
A better one?
- I mean,
what about Rossay Alday?
(audience coos)
Or how about Farrah Rossett?
(Drew and audience gasp in awe)
(audience applauds)
- [Ross] Farrah Rossett.
- I mean...
- That's so good.
- I was like, Mm-hm, mm-hm,
Mm-hm!
- There we go.
- Farrah Rossett.
- And how about for you Drew?
- Motley Drew.
- Oh.
(Ross claps)
- I mean, I am rebellious.
- Yeah.
What about you, Sean Bunch?
You got one for you?
- Yeah.
- Oh, yeah.
Well I'm Miss Ruby Troutman.
- (laughs) Shantay, you stay,
I really like that.
- Oh, yeah.
(audience applauds)
It was the most beautiful day.
- Well done, well done.
(bright music)